welcome to beyond Corp in a bottle where
we explore journeys into the world of
context where access and zero trust
networking as your modern applications
evolve and grow you end up with a set of
services apps deployments and resources
that need to interact with each other
often across disparate networks these
tend to grow organically and that
quickly gets messy or downright
unmanageable let's look at eat and run a
small startup catering to joggers hikers
and power walkers who get peckish
on-the-go they've been growing quickly
since launch and have some pretty
personal information about the clients
that they need to secure they knew that
fully open access wouldn't work for
their systems to high risk of leaks
adding layers of firewall rules quickly
became unmanageable so they turned to
identity wear proxy along with identity
and access management to solve this
after they set up some basic IP access
controls they wanted to go further the
product team got excited about new
social sharing features being developed
in the app and they needed to keep these
features quiet until they were ready for
primetime so they pushed a new version
of the app engine back-end live we used
to restrict it to just the engineering
team for internal testing to further
protect the innovations they had brewing
the evening on security team made the
development version of their web app
restricted to people using up-to-date
Chrome OS devices with a screen lock so
no data might leak inadvertently through
snooping or lost laptops these sorts of
access policies can be defined quickly
in access context manager or via a Yama
file the inrun team realized that a
binary policy was too simplistic for
their needs so they decided to set up
free trust tiers breakfast lunch and
supper
these access levels are based on the
status of the employees operating system
screen lock and disk encryption and help
I ap decide whether or not a given
request gets to the protected apps now
that you eat and run team can enjoy some
peace of mind knowing the only the right
people on secure devices will be able to
play with these new features take a look
at the blog post link below to see more
details on how the team set up these
access controls and figure out if you
qualify for breakfast or lunch at eat
and run thanks for watching subscribe
here to get more videos on context where
access when it comes to protecting your
company keep your data yours
[Music]